let's talk about this steelers roster
position by position let's begin with
naji harris and we talked about this
earlier in the week the the moment where
naji harris realizes that unlike alabama
where media is nowhere close to a
practice session they actually are
present for what happens for portions of
an nfl practice
they are and we saw you today with a
one-handed catch uh also nearly come
down with one that was three we saw that
i saw that and then you almost caught
one that was thrown behind right here
we were there watching yeah
where are you guys at
we're up on the balcony
but uh
boosters
that's crazy
sorry chris i gave you the fake out on
the throne every once in a while as i'm
setting it up i ask myself is he gonna
realize does he know is he reading the
no i'm not reading the sheet yeah you
know obviously today obviously the
answer is no no some days it's yes some
days it's coincidence well sometimes i'm
feeling most days it's coincidence well
sometimes it's more obvious that i'm
making the throw well yeah well and you
know it's like we get into conversations
and we're talking and i got other things
open and i'm kind of looking at and then
i'm like oh wait he's throwing to that i
mean that's hilarious first off boosters
yeah yeah the rooney's got the rooney's
got boosters up there that's what
they're doing uh but i i like naji
harris though yeah and again he's got
that electric smile he can say whatever
the hell he wants as long as he chases
it with that smile oh
agreed he's got got a way about him
that's you know very infectious that way
and you know when you talk about like a
player
attitude everything being the perfect
fit right i mean it just seems the right
way
yeah you know alabama running back you
know alabama one of the few teams that
still does smash mouth type stuff
running the ball going to pittsburgh you
know and and yeah we're gonna you know
just start up a new toughness on the
offensive side of the ball
all right and he can do all those type
of things and then catch the ball out of
the backfield you know i i expect to see
a whole lot of him i don't expect to see
much running back by committee at all in
pittsburgh
and just knowing mike tomlin i think
he's going to
love this guy
pump him up to the team
love the size and physicality he brings
to the team
and he's going to want to they're
they're going to try to make this the
next levy on bell that's what they're
going to do power football power
football power football oh wait now
they're in the empty formation he's in
the slot he's a really good route runner
and that's where i think they're excited
about naji harris and what he can do
there
yeah and kevin colbert the gm of the
team said on pft pm a couple of weeks
ago this is a three down running back
and they haven't had that since le'veon
bell how do we feel about their overall
backfield though when we factor in
harris benny snell anthony mcfarland
caleb
feels when you add harris feels more
potent yeah than it's been in a long
time it's it's it's complete now he
makes it feel complete like
it was if it was without him you're
going ooh they need something else or
someone there's got to be something else
there now you've got the stud and you
got guys that can fill certain roles
behind it that way benny snell similar
but not as good right so he could be the
power guy to go along with it jalen
samuels can do a little bit of
everything he's a swiss army knife a
little bit as far as a running back you
know he's a fullback he's a tailback
he's a you know an h-back as far as an
extra tight end and then you got
mcfarlane anthony mcfarlane who's kind
of like a jitterbug where they tried to
get him involved a little bit last year
i think he could be that guy that's kind
of the change of pace guy off of naji
harris so yeah it's a pretty
well-rounded group now i think when you
look at it especially with him at the
helm
he's kind of become the forgotten man
jaylen samuels in pittsburgh i remember
you were hot on him when he was a rookie
a few years back but uh that they've got
a lot of flexibility now but i think as
you say it's all going to run through
jalen or not jaylen
harris uh receiver
a a significant strength on this team
especially with you just miss schuster
back he's going to have a hard time
getting playing time and i saw that he
said not that long ago that he's going
to be playing more on the outside i we
got deontay johnson chase claypool james
washington i don't know where
juju fits into the outside game i i
would think he would want to be the guy
who can take advantage of favorable
matchups underneath when you've got the
guys on the outside who are attracting
the extra attention yeah no i i don't i
don't think you're wrong there with that
thought mike i don't you know juju the
good thing he has like and i think
you're saying like yeah he's probably
he's made for the slot a little bit more
to your point agreed but the good thing
about him too is because he's such a big
human being he
is an outside threat because he is one
of those guys too that even if he
doesn't beat you he's so big even when
he's covered he's not covered you could
throw back shoulders and jump balls and
those things and i think why
we hear this with him saying you know i
might play outside more is really
because of deontay johnson i think
deontay johnson is an outstanding route
runner and he really even though has
more speed than juju smith schuster he's
made to be
that emanuel sanders type guy right
that's really what he reminds me of as a
player and i i think you know that's why
they drafted him so i would expect maybe
him to take some of that you know role
from juju this year a little bit and
then you got claypool and and juju on
the outside which is damn good and a new
tight end they drafted in the second
round at a penn state so they got some
flexibility with passing weapons for
sure
and and really for for juju it's one
thing to play on the outside it's
another thing to try to be the number
one guy we saw that a couple of years
ago it didn't work because he doesn't
have the speed to stretch the defense
and attract extra attention like an
antonio brown had you mentioned the penn
state tight end taken in the second
round pat freiremuth here he is talking
about the nickname he's already picked
up of baby gronk
pat uh i wanted to ask you about the
nickname baby gronk
i saw that penn state gave that to you
how did that come about and how do you
feel about it
uh
i guess it came about just because i'm
from that area um more 87
obviously growing played for the pages
for a long time grew up you know kind of
watching them
um you know i hate it because you know i
think it's
you know pretty annoying
being called you know
baby but
um yeah i'm trying to get rid of away
that from that nickname so
i don't recall that
free advice to anyone out there that has
a nickname you don't like never say you
don't like it just ignore it just ignore
it it's got a far better chance of going
away if you ignore it especially when
you're a rookie on an nfl team because
all those guys are going to know he
doesn't like it so they're all going to
be calling him baby gronk all year long
what i mean exactly you're spot on if i
heard that right there
the next time i see him walk in the
locker room i'm yelling baby gronk out
loud like you're you're not going to
hear the end of it i'm going to the
equipment guys and going hey let's
change his name plate on top of him and
make it baby grind i mean that's that's
what you're doing you got to be careful
to your point about what you say on a
live mic because the players will use it
against you in a locker room he's yeah i
would never guess that you would be that
one yeah no never right uh but he is uh
he's a really good player and i would be
shocked if he doesn't have a real
influence on the offense this year
he's not
a gronk as far as the way he blocks but
he can be a mismatch as far as splitting
him out he's a very good route runner
you know of course catches the ball well
can do some things after the catch and
that's where i think it's exciting that
they added him to the mix like the first
two picks of the draft i think tell you
that they're changing their attitude
there in pittsburgh oh now we've got
ebron freyr mooth naji harris claypool
and juju smith schuster on the field two
big receivers right to go along with two
tight ends and a big running back oh we
can bring them we can put two tight ends
to the right and bring juju down who's
like a great blocking receiver and now
play smash mouth and like we always talk
about so now a team brings in a
linebacker and now the next play they're
split out and a four wide set and now
you're going uh oh our linebacker's got
to cover ebron or freer moot this isn't
good and i think that's probably what
they're trying to do there in pittsburgh
and that's where i'm i'm very excited
about their new formula
you mentioned eric ebron and
look anytime you see a second round pick
devoted to a tight end
that guy is going to get his
opportunities and ebron has been
yeah
confusing right he's had he's had that
that year 2018 in indianapolis pro bowl
year his first season away from the
lions 66 catches 750 yards 13 touchdowns
great that was great yeah he's otherwise
not lived up to it this is a guy who was
picked in 2014 by the lions 10th overall
with obj on the board with aaron donald
on the board
and he's just never lived up to that
high-end potential that everyone pegged
him to have coming into the nfl no no he
is not you're right and he's been good
yeah it's been good it's not been bad
you take you take a tight end to the top
ten right you expect more yeah you're
right he's never he's only like to your
point had that one year that was like
whoa that's a top 10 tight end type of
year right or top 10 pick type of year
for that tight end uh still really good
in the past game yeah had a little case
of the drops last year right like we
talked about all those things but you
know again i think even with this it
just it it furthers our thought about
pittsburgh and the tampa bay approach
you know again that that's what we saw
in in tampa last year they started to
get good when they said stop putting
three and four receivers on the field
let's put two tight ends on the field
and smash mouth and then when the team
over place their hand to stop the run
brady will dice them up with one-on-one
coverage on the outside and make a great
throw and to me that they can still do
that and big ben's arm is still really
damn good to do it too uh so yeah we'll
see we'll see and hopefully ebron can
can be a big part of that
not that long ago we talked about the
steelers offensive line yeah post free
agency defections alejandro villanova we
have a long time left tackle he's now
gone
what do you i mean here's the big issue
yeah
marquis pouncey right he's gone right
that's a huge that's a huge huge huge
gaping hole in the middle of a line it's
an important function for a center of
any offensive line how hard is it going
to be to replace it uh never easy to
replace a guy like pouncey you know he's
he's seen it all it's like the old
quarterback he can look at a defense and
go oh wait they're going to bring this
blitz hey offensive line slide this way
you know do this this is this and it's
seamless and you take that for granted
sometimes when you're a quarterback or
an office coordinator it's a big hole
they got to fill and we know the
offensive line is a question i mean
you're right but the big thing is too
they have guys on the roster that they i
they believe in let alone they drafted a
guy in the third round but you know when
i think when you look at it with okafor
right coming back and then zach banner
coming back they probably look at that
and go we got our starting tackles you
got to castro back at guard the kid
dachshund started for them last year you
know the rookie out of lsu he's gonna be
there so it is really about jc
haasenauer i hope i said that right
as far as
him in that spot
and we'll see where that goes but i
don't think the
the offensive line questions are as dire
or as desperate as maybe we all thought
towards the end of the season last year
that there is guys on this roster they
believe in who have played and coming
back from injury and all those things to
where i think this could be a quick fix
and a quick change around for this team
all together
all i know is the steelers offensive
line the two years they won the super
bowl in the last decade 05 and 08 was
not good it was one of the biggest
liabilities on the team right and they
still grabbed a couple of lombardi
trophies with that weak link that's rare
that's rare to have happen it helps when
you've got the kind of defense the
steelers have enjoyed forever they're
front seven this year and with all the
focus on offense and it's always offense
offense offense
still a pretty good group even with bud
dupree now at titan after the torn acl
last year still a pretty damn good group
in the front seven for the steelers
defense yeah i mean it's special still i
mean it just doesn't matter whatever you
want to say about it i mean it still
studs with hayward and twoit
you know and and why
and you of course didn't have devin bush
last year who's one of the better middle
linebackers in football
so yeah it's a really good group vince
williams is back
he's still got good play in front of him
it's all going to be just about finding
that other presence to be the edge pass
rush guy
and
i think you know of course they'll
figure that out but it's a front seven
that's got everything as far as you know
versatility depth
uh talent i think that's where you could
be really excited when you have backups
like wormley and tyson allu lou i mean
that's when you know life is pretty damn
good but i think the big question is
that that other edge guy you know who
who takes over there is it high smith uh
but they need that that that pass
pressure presence on that other side of
that defense for sure
during the heyday of the blitzburg
defense when they incorporated the zone
blitz under bill cower it seemed like
every year they'd see a linebacker walk
away in free agency and they'd plug
another guy in and he'd get double-digit
sacks and then that guy's contract
expires and he goes to the next guy and
they just constantly reloaded and
reloaded that position and uh the
secondary
that's
look when you got a great front seven
you don't need a great secondary uh
they've got mega fitzpatrick who ended
up being a great acquisition with a
first round pick they made that trade
september 2019. the rest of it though
joe hayden's been around for a while
stephen nelson's a guy who was cut when
uh just kind of
unexpectedly and and he's still
available no one signed him yet where
where does that
that secondary rank for the steelers and
is that an area of significant concern
for the defense it is for me it is it's
been better than
like at the corner position than maybe i
would have gave it credit for or even
would have thought of going into the
last two years like they've done a
better job covering people man-to-man
and doing that then maybe the names
would lead you to believe in that type
of stuff safety position they're pretty
damn good yeah and you're right they got
minka fitzpatrick who's really special
on the back end but to me that is one of
the things i think that is something i
will look at and continue to evaluate
like with pittsburgh when you look at
their roster i think it's one of the
more concerning things on their football
team you know true cover corners and
again i'd yeah can they match up with a
team like kansas city and do that i
don't know if they can that's what
scares me against you know some of those
more high octane passing offenses uh not
sure how they would match up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports